Let's just jump right into it.
It's, like, whatever, you know?
You're about to get Tuca'd!
Tuca? Tuca?
-Tuca!
-Oh, yeah!
I miss you!
Bertie? Bertie?
Bertie!
You're my best friend. You're smart.
Kapow!
And you're so brave!
Wearing an article of clothing
that's impossible to pee in.
I just pull it to the side.
So, this is my new pet.
You got a jaguar? Are you crazy?
Damn it, Jaguar!
Why do you never wanna have
fun adventures anymore?
Since you've move out,
I feel like something's missing.
Don't talk about me while I'm gone.
We never do.
I have an amazing idea.
-Follow me.
-No!
I'm an adult woman.
I deserve to be treated like a person
and not an object.
So, get out of my space
or I'll break yo' face!
Bertie, watch out!
Shit, shit, shit, shit,
shit, shit, shit, shit,
shit, shit, shit, shit, shit!
Sorry, grandmas. Better luck never.
-We're 30!
-Tell us what menopause is like!
It's a roller coaster.